(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Well, it's been
building up inside of me ♪
♪ For, oh, I don't know how long ♪
♪ I don't know why ♪
♪ But I keep thinking
something's bound to go wrong ♪
♪ But she looks in my eyes ♪
♪ And makes me realize ♪
♪ And she says don't worry, baby ♪
♪ Don't worry, baby ♪
♪ Everything will be all right ♪
♪ I guess I should've kept my mouth shut ♪
♪ When I started to brag about my car ♪
♪ But I can't back down now ♪
♪ Because I pushed the
other guys too far ♪
♪ Oh, what she does to me ♪
♪ When she makes love to me ♪
♪ And she says, don't worry, baby ♪
♪ Don't worry, baby ♪
♪ Everything will turn out all right ♪
(audience cheering)
- Thanks.
Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show," everybody.
Give it up for my band,
y'all, with The Beach Boys.
(audience cheering)
I have to say it, it was
slick before, the stage,
notice that I almost fell one
time, so they made it sticky,
but it was so sticky
that when I tried to do
a little of this, I was like,
"I can't get my left foot up."
Anyway, it probably looked really awesome
and I turned America on with those moves.
That was "Don't Worry, Baby."
In his memoir, Brian Wilson
wrote that he composed it
after hearing the Ronette
song "Be My Baby,"
which is also such a classic.
He heard that for the first time
and apparently, he called
his lyricist right away
and within an hour of
the words being written,
Brian knew he had a hit.
Did you hear it?
(audience laughing)
Still sticking.
I'm not going anywhere, okay?
Like, don't let her break her leg.
Anyway, I love that song so much.
I love the Beach Boys,
it's such a good vibe.